today is the first of September 2023 so
this is my monthly update video in which
I tell you all the stuff that went on in
August that you might have missed and
might want to go back to and all the
stuff that is planned for the month of
September I always like to begin by
highlighting three big things so the
first big thing is a really big thing if
things go right the half hour Hegel
project should be finished up I've got
several more videos to do in the
commentary and then I will be at the end
of absolute knowing and we will finish
up with this book The Battered copy I
have of hegel's phenomenology of spirit
the second big thing would be that
August was a month of lots of cats stuff
for me cat related things and
um that's going to continue on in the
future but I'll tell you more about that
when we get to the August thing I'll
just mention that it's big cats and
little cats and then the third big thing
is keep an eye out I I will be
announcing this in in YouTube and in
social media I am getting close to
Bringing out some online classes in the
study for study with Sadler Academy that
offers you the opportunity to as it says
study with me and I'm you know focusing
mostly on Plato right now but there'll
be some other ones as well
so let's talk about the month of August
I had a lot of big plans they got kind
of sidelined in part because I also got
pretty sick and had to go to the the
doctor and get some antibiotics and
there were days where all I did was
sleep so I didn't get quite so much done
as I would have liked to have gotten
done and we can also add one other thing
on top of it academic classes started
um all the way through most of the
summer I was planning on just teaching
two classes for Milwaukee Institute of
Art and Design namely introduction to
Humanities and ethics for artists and
designers and then Marquette University
as they often do got a hold of me and
said oh we need you to teach some
classes how many can you teach where can
you teach them when can you teach them
and so I took on two additional classes
business ethics and foundations of
philosophy which is basically an intro
class and so I'm teaching four
face-to-face classes this semester now
it's not too bad because I can walk to
Marquette I can walk to my ad and I do
enjoy being in the classroom with you
know young people and getting to talk
with them not mediated by Zoom or Google
meet or teams or any of those sorts of
things so this is quite nice actually
but it does you know take a lot of time
preparing for these classes so I didn't
get quite as much done as I would have
liked to have I did hold my usual ask me
anything session we did our Hegel
sessions as well worlds of speculative
fiction was great we focused on JG
Ballard and his environmental apocalypse
um various books you know from the 1960s
we did an understanding anger session
where we talked about Aristotle mostly
the nick of McCain ethics some of the
politics bits of other works as well
did a Sadler story time where I read
Ursula K Le Queens the rule of names and
Dan and I were able to get together and
do another
um uh you know radio show which then of
course we video recorded the wisdom for
Life show and that one focused on
something that we're discussing in my
business ethics classes stakeholders
versus stockholders conceptions of uh
who we should pay attention to it was
also kind of an interesting month in
that I had my birthday and my wife and I
spent that out at the Big Cat Rescue and
education center and that was pretty
amazing because they've got you know
lions and tigers no bears but instead uh
a black leopard and a lynx and some
servalls and also a little liger or
liliger uh the Giant in there is as well
and you know you you stay there
overnight what that lets you do is like
listen to the cats roaring and chuffing
in the middle of the night but also
gives you some special time where the
park is essentially closed and you get
to you know you you can see the
enclosures right there about six feet
away from you separated by a fence so
obviously you can't like touch the
animals or anything like that but you
can get pretty pretty close and uh you
know getting to do that in kind of an
exclusive way that was so cool we really
enjoyed it and then this month you know
I've been going to almost home cat
rescue here in Milwaukee and I started I
completed all the training I've become a
volunteer and I did my first shifts as a
volunteer this last month of August I'm
signed up for doing some more shifts and
it's a great shelter great place I
really enjoy doing stuff with the cats
there that gets me my my cat fix and I
don't bring any of them home and you
know they they're going to get adopted
so I'm helping to not just you know take
care of their litter and food and water
and stuff like that but give them some
socialization give them some attention
and I really enjoy that
coming back to my you know work that I
think that you know me for
um I did manage to get two half hour
Hegel videos produced this month I
released one of them to the public I'll
be releasing the other one later on and
um that takes me pretty close to the end
of the phenomenology I also did two
Sadler's stories you know these are
videos where I'm reminiscing about
things that might be of interest to you
I did also manage to do three interview
videos and the ideas that matter Series
so that's really cool uh one with Krista
Tomlinson about negative emotions and
why it's probably good for us to
experience them one with my friend and
colleague Donald Robertson about
Psychotherapy and stoicism and exercises
and then uh just towards the very end of
the month one with uh Professor Nancy
Sherman also uh you know somebody I'm
happy to call a friend and colleague and
that one was about some of the back
history of studies of Aristotle and and
stoicism over the last you know 50 60
years but also talking about those
philosophies and her involvement in
military ethics so links to all of those
are below I did one book review of
interestingly a children's book about
stoes ISM I did a quick takes video
something I thought people needed to
hear about and I did one caption contest
video and then you know core concept
videos it's been a while
um since I promised to do this and I
finally got to it I created videos on
Thomas aquinas's five ways on each one
of the ways of arguing for God's
existence doing that in part because I
need those for my classes right and then
I did some on well another important
text that I need for my classes Alistair
McIntyre's plain persons and moral
philosophy I'd done Three core concept
videos in the past on that I did an
additional four this month covering all
the main ideas in that work and I did a
lot of uh podcast work as well releasing
you know quite a few of them
finished up Robert Audi's virtue ethics
as a resource in business which is a
text that I you know teach in my
business ethics classes but also in my
other professional ethics classes then I
did Milton Friedman's a social
responsibility of businesses to increase
its profits not a text I agree with but
one that I teach in class uh Ursula K Le
guins the wizard of Earthsea 10 podcast
episodes Each of which is over 20
minutes about that particular text and
all the different things going on in it
and then finally I've started releasing
Norman Bowie a conscient approach to
business ethics podcast episodes on that
guess why because I'm teaching business
ethics and I I'm going to need those for
my own students but you know you can
listen to them as well and perhaps
benefit from it so that is the month of
August
foreign
what is coming up this month of
September well we're kicking it off
tomorrow with two things one at noon you
know first Saturday of the month I
always hold my AMA that's asked me
anything session this is where you get
to come in and ask me questions they can
be about philosophy how to study
literature more generally
philosophical practices life issues also
people ask me about heavy metal or about
you know my my past or things that I
think about various matters so if you
want to join in
um you know feel free to pop in and then
following that at 2 pm these are all
Central Time Of course because I live
here in Milwaukee
we will have our philosophy chat for
patreon supporters so that's a little
bit more intimate it's video
conferencing and uh you know we go into
more depth and detail than I do in the
amas and then jumping for forward about
a week we have worlds of speculative
fiction and this time around we are
looking at Thomas legati and not just
his fiction his short stories but also
his his book a conspiracy against the
human race and we're looking at his
philosophical horror stuff going on and
he's been a big crowd favorite people
have been asking me to do stuff on him
for years so if you're interested in
that show up at noon Central we'll have
a video premiere live chat that you can
join in and then we'll follow it up with
a video conferencing in Zoom
on the 13th which is Wednesday at 5 p.m
I'll be having my usual monthly Hegel q
a session sponsored by my patreon
supporters of the half hour Hegel
project
um half of our Hegel project is coming
to a close so this is likely going to be
one of the last of these sessions that
we we hold for the public so you might
want to make sure to put that on your
calendar then on the 16th a Saturday at
noon understanding anger 2.0 we are
coming back to literature looking at
Ashley's
orestaya his Trilogy of of tragedies
having to do with um you know Agamemnon
and uh you know his his son orestis
who's placed in a terrible situation by
the murder of Agamemnon so we're going
to go into how anger figures into all of
that on the 23rd
um at noon as well we'll have a video
premiere of the next uh self-directed
study in philosophy Sadler's advice
videos I haven't yet decided who I'm
going to focus on for this month I'm
leaning heavily towards Thomas Hobbes
but I don't know maybe we need to do
some some more stuff about medieval
philosophy to fill in that I mean we've
got lots of gaps that we need to get
into so in any case we'll be doing that
and then finally on the 29th we have a
local event that I'm taking part in at
the Women's Club of Wisconsin here in
Milwaukee it is a thing called
philosophy eats where we have a dinner
conversation Revenue goes to the club to
help support things and we are talking
about a topic that I've been researching
for a very long time and I've done some
presentations on the eight tastes or
flavors as understood in ancient
philosophy and medicine as opposed to
the only four or sometimes five with
Umami that people recognize today in
ancient uh times they recognized a wider
range of flavors and devoted a lot of
thought and attention to how this would
actually work so that's going to be a
cool event
um
got a lot of you know class work I'm
going to be doing I'm still working with
a lot of clients so I'm I'm pretty busy
I need to start getting more uh
routinely back to the gym because
getting sick meant that I couldn't go to
the gym for a while uh I need to start
doing that and fitting that into my
schedule and getting in some more of my
nice long walks about town
um and uh we're gonna have a lot of cool
stuff coming up half hour Hegel is going
to come to a close we're going to be
filming those videos and probably
releasing all of them to the public this
month I'm guessing I'm going to do some
more interviews I've already got one
already recorded that'll be out pretty
soon with uh Jimmy nuts who you might
know from his uh YouTube booktube uh
Channel I just got a lot of cool stuff
but he was also a pro wrestler and we're
going to talk about that and then I've
got a couple other people lined up for
interviews as well I'm going to do some
more book reviews we got those kind of
hanging over my head for a while and
I'll do some more personal stories
um you know Sadler's stories maybe a
quick takes we'll see what what I
actually am able to get to I'm going to
be doing core concept videos on
Aristotle's Poetics in part because I
have my students studying tragedy so
Aristotle's Poetics is a classic Source
text for understanding it and uh I I
promise to get to this last month didn't
get to it this month but I'm hoping that
I can start shooting some core concept
videos on Emmanuel kantz prologomina to
any future metaphysics a text that
people have been asking about for a long
time I've been wanting to get to for a
long time so hopefully we'll be able to
do that uh what else is going on you
know I'm doing some writing I actually
submitted a proposal we'll see if I get
accepted or not about Borges and Greek
philosophy I'm working on a piece from
my APPA in uh not interview but uh
presentation at the annual conference
about resources for anger management and
ancient philosophy that I'll be writing
up and it's going to be in a special
edition coming out this fall
um and I've got a lot of other writing
to handle as well which you can
typically fine in medium but I'm going
to be branching out into some other
places as well and then podcasts
um I'll I'm going to finish up with the
Norman Bowie stuff about conscient
business ethics which is not an oxymoron
there's actually he makes a good case
about that and then I've got another
very short sequence on John Hospers what
libertarianism is for my business ethics
students
Aquinas has five ways I've been turning
those into podcast episodes which uh
hopefully be releasing pretty soon and
then for some of my other classes I've
got stuff on Plato's Republic Book 2
which I need to edit and turn into
podcast episodes
so we'll see what I can do after that it
might be some Aristotle it might be some
other speculative fiction stuff it might
be who knows but that is what we have
planned for the month of September I
hope that you can join me for some of
these events and that you have a great
and productive and hopefully healthy
month ahead of you and maybe I'll see
you in some of these venues and if you
happen to be in the area you know and
you want to say hello to me if you see
me out somewhere come up and say hello
people do that to me all the time
in various places at first it was a
little weird but now I'm kind of used to
it so that's it from me for this month